[Musique]
l'avion n'a été polis prison la justice
saisie des manteaux sans tapis rouge
grâce à sa passion crois tu peux pas
demander mieux c'est impossible
parce qu'on vient costumes un milieu en
bas du bâtiment la galère
à nevoy qui a sorti à l'apex avec la
petite pochette
là
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
salut ses amours et je vous emmène sur
les marches du festival de cannes là bas
j'ai suivi les acteurs du film rodéo
quand j'avais tourné bike life qui est
sûre brut x j'avais suivi junior un
passionné de motocross et quelques mois
plus tard et jouer dans un film qui
s'appelle rodéo et qui aujourd'hui
sélectionné au festival de cannes dans
la catégorie un certain regard si on se
refait le planning on reprend le monde
se prépare et l'idée c'est qu'on monte
les marches rouges à la séance de 22
heures ça va être un moment quand même
assez émouvant qu'enfin attendez vous à
quelque chose de
vraiment mémorable quoi et gagnent ici
vient pas ou pas parce que ma mission va
l'insulté lui alors est où ici comment
tu arrives tu es chez toi là
c'est mon dernier jour dans le 93
ensuite je montais les marches
bien vêtu d'un smoking pailleté et d'une
chemise en soie
jeu nantais ne marque pas
bonjour et la v60 est originaire
voilà ce qu'on ait dépenses il suit là
tu vois par exemple on propose le payer
pour refaire le tournage la vie de ma
mère j'ai moi même je paye c'était un
truc je savais pas j'allais aimer c'est
en c'est quoi comme moi je suis un peu
le méchant le début a cherché pas
méchant
pas tant parce que le mien avec bon jeu
face au toque orange a été témoin
d'aucun ce deuxième festival au monde il
ya la coupe du monde et ont tous été sûr
de gagner c'est vrai ça vient ça ça peut
passer ses jumelles les années passent
mais la baisse avait pour moi
non je la ferme à técou il va faire
chaud des jeux mettra super bien frères
haddad douilles
je mets une petite paire de tn
maintenant la non claquette non mais
brême
puis ça fait des années
frérot façon là à la maison
oh
on est chez phone et c'est mon coiffeur
ça fait des années ça bouge pas si c'est
tous les vendredis tous les vendredis
coiffeur obligatoires
donc connaît là c'est cannes
je connais vraiment pas
jamais su ça
jamais jamais si moi je regarde les
films c'est tout
on est très
posé beaucoup rage
c'est fini
et ouais
y'a déchets c'est maintenant alors il a
un souci ces coiffes des pros m il
faudrait qu'il prenne un peu de ventre
vous attendez à ça ou pas comment ça
s'est passé en fait pour le film comment
vous allez y vous en a parlé et tout
c'est un menteur
il dit pas tout c'est un petit
cachottier c'est à dire on vraiment
parler m'a demandé qu'est ce que j'en
pense et c'est moi qui lui ai dit je lui
ai dit écoute dans la vie on a des
opportunités faut les prendre ça stresse
pas pour demain non non non je suis même
pas stressé je suis pressée au contraire
j'ai pressé je vais retrouver mes potes
ça va me rappeler le film un peu tout
donc ouais ça va être bien je pressais
même le grand père est content il a eu
les larmes aux yeux comme un
toit et de lassus il lui a montré un
petit peu et les larmes aux yeux ça fait
plaisir au nom bah oui ça fait plaisir
ça fait plaisir j'ai vu ce tempo courant
je savais même pas qu'ils savaient
qu'avec
je suis un petit peu un peu responsable
de cette situation
pense pas parce que
j y en a 5 ans il faisait de la moto
quoi
moi j'ai toujours été en retard donc à 8
ans il voulait déjà asser 85 sa page me
de moto
tiens il est comment junior décrire
comment l'homme tentait
[Musique]
alors la sympathique
gentil
mais avant en fait c'était un enfant qui
tenait tête à thomonde
mais quand même aujourd'hui
ça m'a changé mais j'aurais dû arrêter à
cannes avec lui
ça va déranger
je serais bien en marche serait
peut-être passer devant toi et moi on
réprime un point des troubles
aujourd'hui nous sommes en immersion
avec l'équipe de rodéo il fait super
chaud on avec amour et voilà suivez mon
qui à l'arrivée
stressé ouais mais c'est chaud il fait
bon
ouais c'est la toute première fois
il ya du monde
on n'aurait pas imaginé vraiment
être à cannes quoi c'est compliqué ce
genre de sujet le cros bitume qui est
assez
mal vu enfin on en parle de mal je pense
on informe mal les gens ce qui est
dommage parce que hormis des gamins qui
foutent le bordel sur une moto comme on
peut entendre la plupart du temps ben il
y a une vraie cohésion un truc d'equipe
de famille tout le monde est dans la
même bulle en fait finalement on est
tous là pour la même chose vous
vous avez 9-10 ans quelque chose comme
ça c'était la moto de mon frère son père
lui en acheter une et du coup on se les
partager un peu en se disant baladi
comme on est que tous les deux il ya une
moto bas on partage on apprend tous les
deux ont depuis après j'ai plus jamais
arrêté même après les frayeurs
bon bah je t'embarque avec moi dans mon
ascenseur hommes et ces grands je vais
m'ennuyer c'est toute seule j'ai le rôle
de julia une jeune femme un peu
caractère marginal est en fait elle à la
conquête de reconnaissance je pense du
d'un entourage d'une sorte de famille et
va rencontrer une bande de riders qui
vont un peu l'emmener à droite à gauche
mais je pense que c'est surtout julia
qui les emmène à droite à gauche
or plaqué les numéros vas-y bouge de là
bougez te dis
comment gérer une amazone brad a refondu
rêve indiqué denner
[Musique]
nouvelle
lire
thouars quoi ton histoire en toile est
similaire à l'histoire de rodéo la
recherche de se dire
[ __ ] ouais je ressemble à une femme
mais je suis capable de faire la même
chose qu'un homme en fait ceux des cases
et du genre féminin et de prouver que
ouais ok je ressent peut-être à ce que
vous appelez une femme mais je suis
capable de faire ce que vous vous dites
faire des choses de bonhomme quoi pour
moi la bac life à cannes c'est
complètement fou quoi c'est
comme si la bourgeoisie nous accepter un
tout petit peu du genre on vous laisse
entrer chez nous c'est tellement une
ouverture mais tellement grande sur un
nouveau monde et puis on travaille et
notre travail reconnu ça c'est cool
c'est tellement libérateur d'être sur sa
moto j'ai encore pas les mots quand on
me demande de décrire c'est tellement
une chose en fait c'est un je sais pas
je me suis jamais drogué mais j'imagine
ça comme un énorme shoot en fait un
shoot où tu diras [ __ ] ouais c'est ça
encore encore encore voici oui bah ça ça
va tu mets pas
je pense qu'on est tous dans le même
état d'esprit dans ma famille c'est
qu'on ne le réalise pas encore vraiment
je pense et
c'est mieux comme ça après tu me diras
comme ça il ma famille me mets pas de
payet dans les yeux et moi je restais à
terre mais on est super content en fait
on est super contents et on n'a pas
l'impression de vivre
l'histoire c'est en fait une petite meuf
qui a la dalle qui est passionné de moto
qui a ça dans le sang qui a vu l est
comme tous les mecs qui s'y rendra
devrait être soit une infime chance ou à
la fin de motos à la fin des sens est là
elle a la dalle une heure pour pouvoir
rouler et elle a ce rapport là aussi
avec les mecs qui est très j'ai grandi
conflictuel parce que
c'est dur pour une meuf dans un univers
comme ça tu à capter
les motos sur le tapis rouge on essaie
de s'arranger ce serait une première
comme aussi
incroyable là on n'a même pas rouler et
on est tous libérés parce qu'on est nous
gardons unis doivent pourtant que par
compassion
non là c'est bien on sait qu'on va
passer un bon moment les gens nous
attendent et c'est à nous ça me fait
plaisir on dit fier on est tous firent
même
problème chez nous l'eau par une voix
congre assassin
a pas de raison d'avoir la pression pour
montrer à tout le monde qu'on a un
talent mais qu'on aimerait passer au
dessus de tous les préjugés qui les
préjugés envers et cette fois ce sera du
lourd
ouais
complémentarité de ce nom
mois ci un coup de mascara est vaste
le blanc c'est très bien
je ne vois pas la journée très bon choix
je pense que je devrais avoir de la
pression mais je suis plus excité ce qui
est tout le monde va voir le film enfin
on va pouvoir tout sans parler son
ascension et c'est cool on espère que ça
va plaire
tu y avoir
dix
incroyable ce tournage d' incroyable ce
film
je n'ai pas vu mille incroyable aussi
ce genre de planète a une attitude alors
que des mois
sinon une chance qu'il n'a rien compris
à la jet-set encore et bientôt
franchement comme toi non je prends pas
mon ami mais l'homme n'a ici
[Rires]
sport
au festival de cannes gazza goetz à
paris qu'on va aller voir le film pour
la première fois pour la plupart de
l'équipe
ces mois là oui vous allez voir rodéo
c'est le meilleur film de l'année j'sais
pas si vous êtes au courant vous allez
voir c'est le meilleur film de l'année
j'arrive bisou à tout à l'heure
non
elle est de 0 0
première
les rouge et noir
[Musique]
vous avoir tous c'est juste très très
fort très puissant
safin qui s'est fabriqué vraiment dans
le bruit et la fureur le tournage a été
d'une intensité folle et vraiment je
tiens à remercier
l'équipe qui est aux grands y est j je
crois vraiment merci du fond du coeur
[Applaudissements]
que la
caresser c'est un truc de ouf on viendra
de ce milieu là pour la plupart d'entre
nous c'est le premier cas c'est le
premier film on a au festival de cannes
[Applaudissements]
j'espère que cette vidéo vous a plu et
si vous voulez voir d'autres contenus
d'autres portages c'est sur la page
youtube de brut à bientôt